"The Science of Us" presents "The Positives of Negative Thinking."
Everywhere you look, people are urging you to be positive.
Telling you that you're more likely to achieve your goals...
...if you think you're definitely going to achieve them.
But here's a surprise in scientific finding.
Optimism can actually hold you back, and a little bit of pessimism can be a big help.
That idea comes from the work of Gabriele Oettingen,...
...a German psychologist who's been studying optimism since the 1980s.
In 1991, she studied a group of women in a weight loss program.
Before the program began, she asked them to predict how well they'd do...
...and she was shocked to find that the women who were pessimistic about losing weight,...
...who thought the process would be difficult and that they might not succeed,...
...actually ended up losing an average of 24 more pounds than the positive thinkers.
Over and over again, she found that positive fantasies...
...didn't help people achieve their goals.
And in fact, often got in the way.
Here's her theory about why.
When you indulge in starry-eyed dreaming about the future,...
...you start ignoring the tasks in front of you.
Instead of pushing yourself to go to the gym or study for a test,...
...you just happily imagine having big muscles or good grades,...
...and don't feel much motivation to get to work.